hay que prepararse para un posible brote
de cólera lo advierte la oficina
humanitaria de la onu tras el terremoto
el riesgo de brotes de cólera es
especialmente preocupante en el sureste
de afganistán donde los casos de diarrea
acuosa ya estaban aumentando antes del
terremoto de ayer se están llevando a
cabo preparativos para evitarlo el
organismo también estaba intentando
verificar si las operaciones de búsqueda
y rescate estaban casi terminadas a un
90% como aseguró el gobierno talibán
contra esa versión oficial contrasta la
incertidumbre por la suerte de las
poblaciones remotas donde las malas
comunicaciones y la falta de carreteras
adecuadas obstaculizan los esfuerzos de
socorro nocturno balas no hay a nadie el
departamento de salud y todos estaban
haciendo lo que podían por su cuenta los
niños quedaron atrapados bajo los
escombros y regresé y los evacuó las
tumbas son cavadas una tras otra por
residentes que solo tienen sus propias
manos para limpiar las calles un ejemplo
flagrante de la falta de recursos en el
país miles de millones de dólares en
activos afganos fueron congelados
después de que los talibanes
al poder el pasado agosto y gran parte
de la ayuda extranjera de la que depende
el país fue cortada naciones unidas
estima que 23 millones de afganos
incluidos miles de niños se enfrentan a
una hambre aguda agravada por las
sequías que han afectado a las cosechas
[Música]
su excelencia el ministro de finanzas ha
ordenado a las autoridades fronterizas
que impidan el contrabando y no permitan
a nadie exportar trigo a
cuestiones humanitarias pero también de
seguridad los atentados terroristas van
en aumento la mayoría reivindicados por
el estado islámico incluyendo un ataque
en una mezquita chiita en octubre que
mató a más de 50 personas